if you ask a roboticist somebody who
studies robots for a living what is a
robot it's actually a very challenging
question to answer my name is Rebecca
Kramer botiglio and I'm a mechanical
engineer and material scientist when you
conjure up an image of a robot you
typically think of rigid machines that
perform repeated tasks and they don't
adapt to their environment because
that's not what they've been designed to
do but when we think of robots for the
future we imagine things like animals
like ourselves we are incredibly
adaptable we adapt our body
configuration and our Behavior toward
different tasks and environments and we
want to design robots that can do the
same and when we look at how animals
adapt to different tasks and
environments what we notice is that all
animals are at least partially soft
there are no known animals in the world
that are completely rigid which is in
contrast to the way that we typically
design robots
and so I study soft robots which are
robots made out of soft materials Soft
Robotics is a broad field touching on
wearables and manipulation
shape-shifting robots and Locomotion
robots my group is developing novel
responsive and intelligent materials and
embedding them into robots that can
perform novel behaviors like shape
change and we draw upon inspiration from
biology we have a turtle and tortoise
inspired robot platform with morphing
limbs Turtles and tortoises are
morphologically very similar but they
differ primarily in their limbs so when
you think of sea turtles you think of
elongated flippers that are relatively
flexible and flat tortoises have rounded
limbs that are better for load-bearing
and terrestrial Locomotion so what we've
developed is a morphing limb platform
that can switch back and forth between a
flipper like morphology and a leg like
morphology and it allows the robot to
accomplish efficient Locomotion both in
water and on land
[Music]
what I love about working in robotics is
all of the intellectual challenges we
have the opportunity to redefine what is
a robot from the ground up